won't won't okay there I got that pizza
you ordered oh Jesus it's sexy the nerd
wars sexy nerd this one two women it's
gonna be Samus Aran versus Catwoman from
Jack's Coby thanks Jack Coby Thank You
Jax Coby I know there's different color
outfits but Wikipedia basically didn't
describe that they were any real reason
to have them fashion but they're hot no
they're not gonna have pink Samus or
yellow salmon that green look if we're
gonna if we're gonna talk about outfits
let's give the point to the warm air
with the 8-bit graphics at the end of
Metroid no let's give a point to the
woman who actually shows some cleavage
can you figure out a pixel between your
fingers I think that's one of those
questions like it's an Rachelle's in the
way vyd what are you talking about where
he was stacked no no she head was about
two pixels Winder boobs each were four
pixels what they're talking about
do you even know what Guin is when you
don't know what clear is there's no base
between no there was there's one white
pixel right here you dick what one white
be honest be honest there's no cleavage
she needs to go back and look I Metroid
this morning Metroid the original got to
the end no you did no I played although
you didn't yeah and there's no you did
not believe on it you did not go today
we can if you can lie I can line point
to Catwoman point to Samus Aran for
being a badass okay so let's just say
they get in a fight they actually go and
fight it out mm-hmm Samus is gonna win
and what would your argument there be
she's got guns she can crawl into a
little ball and spin around and
Catwoman's a cat and she'd just be like
wrong Catwoman has fought and beat
numerous people who didn't roll into
little balls
exactly and that's her wait no no that's
her kryptonite no that's the only power
that the Metroid chick has she can do
somersaults rice is that's like saying
just because Green Lantern can make
[ __ ] kryptonite doesn't mean he can
can't say kryptonite cannot make crit
you
God read a book here's the thing all
right
the only thing the metroid chick can do
is somersault all right and if you enter
into a book if you can't tell you if
you've ever beaten up a two-year-old all
right
they do the same boo don't even try it
they do the same moves
she's got nothing she's a worthless crap
wait your two-year-old can I beat up a
turn into a little perfectly round
sphere hey summers look completely
entertained a cat for hours and hours
and hours on end there's open Samus Aran
would pop out and go BAM missile to the
head
it's not like ISIL to the head it's not
like she's got chozo training Choza what
just because women train with not the
cholos I'll give you that all right name
the best character you think Catwoman
won against the best character like the
most powerful character that Catwoman
actually defeated I believe she defeats
the homeless guy that was the answer I
was gonna say no I was gonna say Bane
faints just a big guy no brains she's a
poor man's mega man and she sucks did
you really just say that yeah I did
better character in the Mega Man a ball
you're right
I know Mega Man vs. Samus Aran Mega Man
will kick her and I go man what since
we're not arguing that it's against
Catwoman and when we lose and the
editing on this is gonna be awesome
because I'm just gonna show Halle Berry
Catwoman don't know all the time okay I
want to make a point here
the Halle Berry Catwoman has nothing oh
no cannon cannon no it's not cannon it's
not cannon it's not a comic book
we didn't a comic book no the same the
same way Captain end all right they had
the chick for Metroid on Captain n-not
cannon I'm gonna invalidate then Samus
Aran in her yellow suit it's just
disgusting
well yeah the yellow suit is gross
catwoman wins okay we want to know what
you think who do you think won yeah
would win know Samus Aran put it in the
comments and let us know if you got
other ones you want to argue yeah and
send us pictures of you somersaulting
because it impresses Jeff so much